[Aplausos]
buenas tardes un privilegio estar aquí
bien hace un par de años leí que los
cuentos están hechos para dormir a los
niños
también sirven para despertar a los
adultos entonces quiero empezar con un
cuento del gran jorge bucay voy a hacer
un mini resumen de este grandioso cuento
que se llama el buscador probablemente
lo conozcas en donde un hombre se lanza
a buscar dejar todo atrás y se lanzó a
buscar una hermosa ciudad y en medio de
su camino voltea a su derecha y se topa
con una gran colina verde llena de
flores llena de fauna preciosa y como
buscador que era le llamó la atención y
se acercó a este lugar entró a la colina
y se dio cuenta que había muchas piedras
blancas alrededor se acercó a una de
ellas y vio que tenía una inscripción en
la descripción decía bien el nombre de
una persona y decía vivió ocho años y
siete meses
díaz leemos la atención voltio alrededor
y vio que no era la única piedra que
tenía inscripciones
se acercó a otra y decía también el
nombre de otra persona
ella vivió 10 años 11 meses 3 días
no caray este lugar tan hermoso y estoy
parado en un cementerio en un cementerio
cualquiera son niños
el buscador se tiró a llorar
desconsolado viendo qué maldición pasa
acerca de este colina en los pueblos
cercanos que tanto niño aquí él estaba
llorando mientras pasó el cuidador de
esa colina de ese cementerio y le dice
el señor qué sucede hay un familiar aquí
de usted pero que tragedia ocurre aquí
hay tanto niño sepultado
el cuidador son realice no no no señor
despreocúpese
sucede que los pueblos cercanos a esta
colina tenemos una tradición en donde
cuando un joven cumple los 15 años de
edad le regalamos una libreta que se la
cuelga al cuello y en ella anota todos
los momentos y sólo aquellos momentos
que realmente son valiosos en su vida no
cualquier momento donde la izquierda por
mí sólo un ejemplo escribe el peso a la
primera novia y escribe cuánto duró esa
bella emocional o el nacimiento del
primer hijo y a un lado cuánto duró esa
emoción una semana un año no lo sabemos
y justo cuando esta persona ya no está
con nosotros hacemos la suma
escribimos justo eso los años realmente
vividos para esta persona 10 años 11
meses 15 días no lo sé
bien si a ti te pudiera ser discúlpenme
pueden poner la presentación adecuada
del abierto capela si te hago aquí esta
pregunta que diría tu libreta
cuántos años diría tu libreta si
realmente pudieras escribir allí
solamente los momentos valiosos de
emoción de tu vida
diez años
de los 90 siguen que vas a vivir solo
eso
cuanto diría apunta a reflexionar al
respecto
ok una pregunta retórica no necesito que
me la contestes en algunos programas de
capacitación o coaching que tenemos para
gente o empresas en específico en uno
específico de gestión de productividad
comenzamos poniendo este caso hipotético
a las personas también les decimos
imagínate qué cada día en tu cuenta
bancaria una institución financiera
depositará 86 mil 400 pesos
qué harías con ese dinero
ponte a pensar en ello qué haría si
diariamente tuvieras 86 mil 400 pesos
permiten así está ya la información
correcta
no es necesario entre las respuestas las
principales respuestas que tenemos la
primera está invertir en propiedades
pero creo que es algo inteligente
la otra es donarlo como donarlo la otra
es viajar por el mundo ok
algo que no les he comentado es que este
dinero que aparece diariamente en tu
cuenta bancaria tiene dos
consideraciones especiales número uno
ese dinero no lo puedes acumular día
tras día es decir que hoy a las 12 de la
noche desaparece ese dinero si no lo
gastaste o si te quedaron 100 pesos
desaparece pero bueno al siguiente día
ya sabes que vas a tener 86.400 otra vez
no pasa nada pero ojo hay una segunda
consideración
en cualquier momento y sin previo aviso
esta institución financiera puede
detener este depósito sin avisarte quizá
mañana te despiertes abras tu cuenta o
vayas al banco y veas que está en cero
ya no hay más dinero para ti
en que lo utilizaría tomando en cuenta
estas consideraciones
bueno estas son las dos continuaciones
que te practicaban ahora la buena
noticia te voy a decir es que tienes
este dinero contigo en realidad solo que
no es dinero
es tiempo
quizá lo que valores más en la vida sea
no lo sé tu salud y la de tus seres
queridos
y quizá el número dos está la lana del
billete
y el tiempo en donde queda porque no lo
valoro igual todos los días tú tienes
86.400 segundos a utilizar como tú
decidas
pero tiene dos consideraciones una es
que no lo puedes ahorrar
hoy a las 12 de la noche si no lo
utilizaste se borra pero que mañana
tengo más otros 86.400 seguro que lo vas
a tener porque la consideración número 2
está en que sin previo aviso de repente
ese dinero ya no lo vas a tener este
tiempo
lo que hace realmente con este tiempo no
tienes tiempo no tienes energía para
hacer que las cosas sucedan y no me
refiero cualquier cosa como preparar una
hamburguesa o ir al cine sino hacer
cosas realmente valiosas para ti te
platico enseguida de lo que te quiero
hablar
un dato que me sorprendió muy reciente
de la organización para la cooperación y
desarrollo económico en donde son
alrededor de 35 países solamente los
miembros entre ellos están méxico es que
entre todas las estadísticas que maneja
esta organización hay una en donde
méxico es el número uno
y de hecho alemania es el último ya le
ganamos a alemania otra vez y en que es
justo es en horas de trabajo promedio al
año
estamos mejor que alemania o mejor en
méxico se trabaja en 2.255 horas al año
en promedio en la alemania solamente se
trabaja en 1363 horas al año promedio en
méxico trabajamos casi 900 horas más
aquí está la gráfica de a qué lado está
méxico este lado está alemania estamos
por arriba de un montón de países como
australia eeuu
pudiera parecer una buena noticia si
realmente fuera equivalente a horas
trabajadas horas de productividad y no
es así
esta estadística es totalmente opuesta a
lo que queremos que sea es decir qué
a pesar que somos el número uno en eso
somos de los últimos en productividad
en los últimos en productividad los que
más trabajamos
y menos productivos
contra alemania que son los que menos
trabajan e increíblemente son más
productivos
inclusive el reino unido en méxico solo
crecimos recientemente el 0.3 por ciento
en productividad no es nada nos quedamos
tablas prácticamente
esto no es una buena noticia trabajamos
mucho y no somos productivos ahora si el
término productividad como les decía
hace rato no puede ser productivo
preparando de comer puede ser productivo
siendo la tarea con tu hijo en tu
escuela en tu trabajo ok yo te quiero
presentar un nuevo concepto que más allá
de simplemente ser productivo es decir
ser efectivo ser eficiente
yo quiero que te enfoques en los
siguientes minutos lo que todas platicar
en ser productivo con valor que es esto
en que vivas una vida de valor como esa
historia que te platicaba al inicio en
donde realmente cada actividad o bien la
mayoría de las actividades que decidas
porque tú decides realizarlas
sean actividades que te acerquen a esas
metas que quieran lograr y quizás no te
has atrevido
y no tiene que ver con administrar el
tiempo de hecho
yo dudo que puedas administrar el tiempo
y el tiempo simplemente pasa
simplemente pasa no lo puedes agarrar y
mete en un cajón para usarlo después
pero lo que sí puedes hacer está en tus
manos y no en la de tu esposo no es la
de tus hijos no la de tu jefe está en
decidir qué hacer con ese tiempo decidir
qué hacer con tu energía esto es si
puedes decidir sobre tus acciones
sin excusas tú puedes decidir cambiar el
rumbo de tu vida en cualquier momento
hoy es que yo no vengo de una cuna de
oro hoy es que yo crecí sin papá es que
me lees excusas se te van a presentar en
tu cabeza y en tu corazón
la realidad es que tú puedes decidir y
quizás sea otro factor que enseguida te
voy a platicar del por qué no haces que
esto suceda
2 te invito a que vivas una
productividad con valor realmente a que
gran parte de tus actividades son sean
estos pasos que se acercan algo y
realmente quieres ser lo que quieres
hacer que realmente te apasiona en tu
vida en un trabajo de porquería no los
estudios que sólo estás ahí porque tu
papá lo es o porque son las expectativas
de tu pareja o de tus amigos
hacer tú ahora bien se practicaba
ahorita en que hay tres factores de
hecho importantes y uno es el tiempo que
tiene disponible
si haces cuenta de realmente si
registras cada centavo es decir cada
segundo cada minuto del que lo inviertes
te vas a dar cuenta que si tienes tiempo
simplemente tienes muchos ladrones del
tiempo
como por ejemplo no está mal que veas
series de televisión en realidad
lo que ya pudiera ser un ladrón de
tiempos que veas un maratón de 8 horas
de series de televisión porque quizás
esas horas le está restando a estos
pasos de valor para llegar un propósito
mayor a ti
no está mal pero en que lo utilizas de
hecho está bien de serie si te amplia la
creatividad ves alguna serie y te relaja
es importante recargar energía también
tienes tiempo y tienes energía también y
ahora decide qué actividad vas a poner
en ese tiempo y con la energía que
tienes tú decides es la cuenta y verás
que si tienes tiempo cuántas horas
trabajadas a la semana no sé diez horas
diarias que son 50 60s de cuentas y te
quedan todavía muchísimas horas para
hacer que las cosas sucedan una hora de
white caps hay brechas que las puedes
utilizar maravillosamente para aprender
grasa la tecnología
cada momento cada vez que me echo un
regaderazo pongo una bocina y pongo algo
en youtube por ejemplo es palabra algo
que me dé algo que me enseñe de acuerdo
al humor que traigo quizás sea de
deportes quizás sea de lo que sea
motivacional etcétera voy transporte al
trabajo sea públicos en el carro lo
aprovecho para ir escuchando pero y
aprendiendo entonces si tengo tiempo
realmente lo puedo aprovechar para
aprender un nuevo idioma no lo sé
productividad con valor no solo hacer
cosas no solo mantenerme ocupado sino
mantenerme motivado haciendo cosas que
me apasionan ahora bien
por cuánto tiempo realmente dedicas a
esas actividades de valor no piensas en
toda la semana piensas y quieras en un
día
cuántas horas dedicas realmente
no me lo contestes piénsalo todo en
actividades que te acercan a lo que
quieres ser a lo que quieres hacer y
quizá involucre a otros también seres
queridos una hora
ocho horas wow maravilloso cuánto tiempo
realmente cuánta energía le pones a eso
esa palabra que está en rojo está quizás
sea el principal
de tractor que tienes que es el miedo
como te platicaba quizás haya personas a
tu alrededor que esperan de ti ciertos
comportamientos ciertas actitudes falsas
expectativas cuando no es realmente lo
que tú eres o lo que tú quieres hacer
vives de acuerdo a expectativas
probablemente de otras personas de tus
hijos de tu pareja y esas creencias las
tienes ya muy arraigadas en tu crees que
pues es que así soy yo no puedo ser de
otra manera claro que si tú puedes
decidir esta palabra en inglés que
spears si lo ponemos letra por letra
podemos grabar como que son falsas
expectativas que tú tienes que
aparentemente son reales o no lo son el
miedo
esto es lo que te detiene en lugar de
potenciar todo aquello que si tienes tú
que si eres
es un detractor para ti yo te invito a
que te atrevas a hacer las cosas que
realmente rompas paradigmas y te salgas
de todo aquello que tú el mismo crees
que eres y puede ser más de hecho tú
eres único tu eres única tú has visto
cosas que yo no he visto tú has visto
cosas aunque tengas un hermano gemelo tu
has visto cosas que es hermano hermana
no ha visto tu has percibido el mundo de
diferente manera a todos los seres de
este planeta
en serio que todos entonces quizá tú
tengas el secreto quizá tú tengas la
solución a un gran invento algo que
puede tener impacto en la comunidad pero
te da miedo utilizar lo que van a decir
ese no soy yo porque nos priva de eso
tan valioso que tienes aquí y que tienes
aquí
los primeros de ello palabra quizá tú
tenga la solución atrévete a hacerlo hoy
es que pues sí tengo pensado hacer
muchísimas cosas pero qué crees no tengo
el recurso no tengo dinero no tengo el
tiempo seguro no es el momento adecuado
fíjate que estoy pasando por una
enfermedad que ok excusas pretextos hoy
es cuando de hecho no existe el momento
adecuado si lo buscas nunca lo vas a
encontrar el momento adecuado es con las
circunstancias que estás atravesando en
este momento es empieza hoy no importa
que tan pequeño sea ese paso pero puedes
hacer algo hoy que te lleve a hacer o
hacer aquello que realmente quieres te
invito a que lo hagas atrévete
a lo que me gusta mucho es esta pregunta
la verdad la tomé de un gran orador
motivador que se les brown
y le lanza esta pregunta a su público y
le dice a ver cuál es el lugar más rico
del mundo cuáles son las respuestas
comunes
eso os ocurre
dubai
qatar para la respuesta que da es muy
poética y si no no es el lugar más rico
del mundo es el cementerio
como el cementerio algo más rico es el
cementerio porque ahí están enterradas
grandes empresas que jamás fueron
creadas
ahí están enterrados libros que te
privas te de escribir para todo el mundo
ahí están enterradas hermosas canciones
que no te atreviste a sacar al público
por miedo ahí están enterrados quizás
curas a enfermedades que no te atreviste
a lanzarlas
ahí también pueden estar encerrados
besos y abrazos que no te atreviste
nunca a dar
con esto yo te invito a que realmente no
prives al mundo
y si te suena muy ambicioso decir el
mundo no prives a tu comunidad no prives
a tu familia no prives a la persona que
tienes al lado todo aquello que sabes
todo aquello que puedes todo aquello que
quieres y no te has atrevido no lo dejes
que alguien más lo haga cuate que tú
eres único y quizás tiene la solución no
el de al lado has percibido el mundo de
otra manera entonces si no eres tú quien
lo va a ser si no es ahora cuándo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]